peuple
[Musique]
attention cet homme est dangereux aussi
georges l'ange lan agents secrets
surprenants personnages a tout fait il
sait tout faire
mais il préfère un vélo à une aston
martin
il est très souvent le matin je viens
comme ça à faire une heure de vélo bois
j'adore ça et puis je vienne bonheur et
venant de bonheur alors qu'il n'y a pas
beaucoup de monde a pas beaucoup de
bruit non plus j'ai découvert des tas de
choses et découvert les animaux
découvert les écureuils du bois et par
endroits je finissais par les connaître
tout au moins ils finissaient par ne
plus avoir peur de moi avait choisi mme
carrière et fait une carrière où on ne
peut pas avoir peur ainsi on a peur tout
le temps les gens qui n'ont pas peur
dans cette carrière ne dure pas
longtemps ils se font prendre
la peur est une ceinture de sauvetage
qui est considérablement
et quand on tue quand vous avez teana
mais ce que vous avez eu peur avant non
absolument parle mais il ya je ne suis
pas un tueur alors j'ai été obligé de
tuer deux fois une fois assez
brutalement et j'étais absolument lucide
je me souvenais de tout ce qu'on m'avait
appris parce que j'ai tué un allemand
avec son propre pistolet et il fallait
que je me remémore en quelques secondes
tout ce qu'on avait appris comment
marchait cette arme d'abord et puis
ensuite comment la saisir car elle était
pointé sur moi et non sur lui et tout
s'est très bien passé en une
demi-seconde à peu près et cet homme
était en train de manger et je lui ai
mis une balle entre les deux yeux
absolument et il s'est vidé sur son
assiette et après je ne sais pas ce qui
est arrivé après mais quand il ya un
trou là dans ma mémoire et quand j'ai
repris ma mémoire je suis dans un fossé
à trois ou quatre kilomètres de
l'endroit où j'avais abattu cet homme et
je tenais toujours cette armée je la
tenais tellement fort qu'elle me faisait
mal dans la main et alors là je les
jetais aussi posé ce qui s'est passé
pendant ce trou
j'ai dû courir j'ai dû battre des
records de vitesse je pense que j'aurais
laissé jazy loin derrière moi à ses
proches de de l'éthique et de la
philosophie james bond oui et non n'est
ce pas quand je vois james bond tenir
une arme un peu comme ma grand mère
tenait son son tisonnier ça me fait
sourire parce que de toute évidence cet
acteur n'a jamais tiré à balles avec une
arme quand dans les films que j'adore
d'ailleurs pour moi c'est du music hall
quand dans ses films je vois bande tiré
et c'est plus fort que moi si vous
voulez quand il tire je regarde où il
tire et je sais qu'il a raté mais le
méchant tombe quand même c'est adorable
c'est absolument merveilleux alors qu'un
véritable agent secret n'a pas d'armes
ce serait trop absurde c'est un homme
qui se promène sans armes bien sûr par
contre on lui donne d'autres armes si
vous voulez il est tout à fait naturel
qu'à nommer sur lui deux boîtes
d'allumettes qu'il est dans la poche de
son veston un journal avec ça on peut
tuer
vous pourriez démontrer la manière de
ressentir avec un journal je pourrais je
ne le ferai pas quoi pour deux raisons
la première c'est que c'est toujours
classés par ed comme on dit en anglais
il est interdit de la révéler et puis la
deuxième c'est que sur cet écran un
enfant pourrait voir sa et l'essayer
demain surfer sur sa petite soeur ou sur
sa grand-mère et ça marcherait vous
savez c'est tellement simple un journal
un journal une boîte d'allumettes
différentes choses comme ça
[Musique]